we're back with more unpopular nutrition
myths that Wellness influencers don't
want you to know eating sugar isn't the
cause of diabetes it's a little more
complicated than that alkaline water
doesn't change your body's pH if it did
Wellness influencers would die
intermittent fasting isn't Magic it
largely works because you just skip a
meal there's the difference between
legitimate bloating and just not having
a flat stomach the latter's something
that we don't need to fix
organic cookies are still cookies how
they're grown doesn't necessarily make
them a health food
drinking coffee on an empty stomach
bursting in the morning won't spike your
cortisol and make you suddenly gain
belly fat gluten-free isn't better if
you're not Celiac or intolerant in fact
most gluten-free products are less
nutritious than their gluten-filled
counterparts honey and maple syrup
aren't much healthier than table sugar
higher in some micronutrients sure but
please don't aim to get your
antioxidants from sugar which of these
nutrition myths are going to rile at the
influencers the most